the media settle on a backup narrative
after their covington hit goes awry
mitch mcconnell takes steps to end the
government shutdown and the millennial
fresh
faces arrive on the scene yay i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show all
righty so i got to tell you i've been
doing the audio read of my book
each evening i just started last night
so i assume it will be more evenings
and i don't mean to compliment myself
that looks great i mean you should
definitely go pick up a copy
in advance and if you haven't then you
should wait until it comes out and then
i'll sign it for you and everything
it'll be great but the book is
i'm really excited about all of it and i
just had to give you that update we're
gonna get to the news of the day because
i have much to say about the news as per
our usual arrangement which is why
you're here but first
let me remind you you got to keep your
house safe that's why you need ring
ring's mission is to make video neighbor
is to make neighborhoods safer
you might already know about their smart
video doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so
if there's a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you'll get an alert
you'll be able to see here and speak to
the person all from your phone which is
great i mean sometimes i'm 3000 miles
away from home and i know who's at my
front door
thanks to hd video and two-way audio
features on ring devices you will make
sure that you know what's going on
on your property at all times we have a
ring video adorable at our house which
is
fantastic because sometimes we have
weird people come up to the house
as a listener you have a special i'm not
talking about my extended family as a
listener
you have a special offer on a ring
starter kit available right now
with a video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight cam the starter kit
has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home
just go to ring.com that is ring.com
ben again when you do that there's a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available for you
just right now go to ring.com use that
promo code
ben to let them know that we sent you
i've been using ring myself
for years and there's a reason for that
ring.com ben
go check them out right now okay so the
covington
story the covington catholic high school
story that blew up the media over the
weekend
has completely imploded in on the media
because it turns out that these kids
from covington catholic high school
really didn't do anything wrong
there's not a lot of evidence they did
anything wrong they were standing there
to recap the story among they were
standing there
after the march for life some of them
were wearing maga hats which apparently
is now crime in the united states and
we're supposed to know that maga hats
are innately offensive and triggering to
people the maga hats
ooh triggering and they're standing
there after the march for life
and they started being harassed by the
black hebrew israelites a bunch of cult
members
who are mostly known for being ignored
on the new york subways
and then a native american guy walked up
into the middle of the group banging a
drum stood face to face with a guy named
nick sandman who's apparently 17 years
old goes to covington catholic high
and nick sandman just stood there kind
of awkwardly and
this was enough cause for people to lose
their ever-loving minds well nick
sandman appeared
on the today show this morning with
savannah guthrie it is amazing to watch
the media attempt to twist their way out
of this
by trying to cast aspersions on the 17
year olds whose great sin was standing
there on his feet
in a public place at one of the most
visited places in america not moving
with a mild smile on his face trying to
defuse the situation
he's the bad guy why because one he wore
a maga hat and two because he's a white
religious kid so here's savannah guthrie
trying to make that case
do you feel from this experience that
you owe anybody an apology
do you see your own fault
in any way as far as standing there
i had every right to do so
i don't i my position is that i was not
disrespectful to mr phillips
i respect him i'd like to talk to him
i mean in hindsight i wish we could have
walked away and avoided the whole thing
okay this is insanity this is insanity
salmon is
obviously scared right he's obviously a
little bit dear in the headlights right
there because
he's got the entire national news media
on his case
in his face specifically because he
committed the grave terrible sin
of standing in a place not doing a thing
and then it continued along these lines
this this today show
interview you know she was asked he was
asked then about wearing a maga hat this
clip 13.
he was asked specifically about wearing
a maga hat right maybe that was the
problem
the problem wasn't that he was standing
there doing nothing the problem is that
he was wearing a hat
and that hat makes people angry and
because he was wearing an angry making
hat
a hat that makes folks lose their minds
probably it's his fault because he was
wearing the hat bad bad kid wearing a
hat you know you got to be careful the
hats you wear
that that red that red hat's basically
like a kkk hood except that it's not
in any way here's savannah guthrie
trying to make that point
you think if you weren't wearing that
hat
this might not have happened or it might
have been different that's possible
but i would have to assume what mr
phillips was thinking
and i'd rather let him speak for why he
came up to us
the conflict has caught the president's
attention he tweeted that sandman and
his classmates were treated unfairly and
have become
symbols of fake news okay and trump is
of course correct about that i do love
that savannah guthrie is asking about
the evils of the hat
the evils evils of that now what's
amazing is that this has become
what people have focused in on is the
evils of the head i'm not kidding you
ruth graham over at slate which is
another one of these media repositories
for leftist stupidity she writes a piece
today and the title is the magatines
aren't innocent victims
okay and i love this the incident at the
lincoln memorial was more complicated
than it initially seemed
it's the reverse of what you made it out
to be guys like the precise reverse
the people who were offending here were
not the kids it was the black hebrew
israelites and nick phillips or nate
nathan phillips who walked into the
crowd in an attempt to draw
attention and then lied about the
situation repeatedly
okay but i love this new footage
according to ruth graham doesn't
exonerate the kids
in the red caps and i i love that what
they say is that the the maga hats
themselves
were the problem right she says none of
this might have mattered and the clip
certainly would not have gone viral
if sandman and many of his peers were
not wearing a red were not wearing
red make america great again hats racks
reported in 2017
that the hats would become popular
souvenirs among white teenage boys
visiting washington
in part because they invite instant
attention instant discomfort
easy transgression boston globe
columnist renee graham wrote last summer
about seeing more than a dozen white
teenage boys in maga hats
at the national museum of african
american history and culture clearly
this was meant as a provocation she
wrote
i'm inclined to believe that sandman too
is smart enough to understand that the
maga hat
is not a symbol of peace and
reconciliation especially when the bill
of that hat
is inches from the nose of a native
american
the native american guy walked up to
nick sandman if we are now going to
assume what's in the head of everyone
who wears a maga hat
and by the way if you want everyone in
the maga hat to think like ruth graham
is suggesting they think keep doing this
stuff really if you want everybody who
wears a mega hat to think of it as a
symbol of the resistance all you have to
do
is keep maligning everyone who voted for
trump as a secret racist who is racist
for standing there and having a face
that's really what they're saying now
they're saying he was standing there he
had a face
his face was kind of smiling very bad
very very terrible and then i love this
so nick sandman and his peers get
absolutely savaged by the media
they're doxxed their school is canceled
basketball games cancelled
death threats the whole shebang and
chris hayes from msnbc says you know
what the problem is
the real problem here is that these kids
have privilege
he's the privilege of being targeted by
the media for wearing a hat and being
human and standing on feet
chris hayes writes the most vital
privilege in american life is due
process second chances and the grace to
have your actions read charitably
i understand why people will fight like
hell to preserve it but probably worth
thinking about all the people who do not
have those privileges at all
yeah i'm sure the the real story here is
the white privilege of the kids who had
their lives basically overturned
for no reason because the media decided
to go after people
i love the perception by a lot of
mainstream media actors
that the constant savage attacks on
people who are not of the left wing
that's evidence that those people have
privilege in and of themselves and maybe
when we get it wrong the real story is
the privileges that the people
that we're not attacking don't have the
real story isn't what happened to these
kids it's what happens to other kids
that we're not talking about or
targeting for destruction
it's not a point i'm making by the way
conor friedersdorf over the atlantic
makes that point he's a lot more
libertarian to the left than i am but
it's
the the constant stream of false
information continues virtually
unabated so ilhan omar who is one of the
fresh faces of the new congress fresh
fresh so fresh
so she tweeted this out she tweeted the
boys were protesting
a woman's right to choose and yelled
it's not rape if you enjoy it number one
false the kid who was caught on tape
yelling that is not from covington
catholic high school
two she says they were taunting five
black men before they surrounded
phillips and led racist chance
false on every single score there is no
evidence they led racist chance
nor were they taunting the people from
the black hebrew israelites the people
from the black hebrew israelites were
calling them the f word
for gay people and they were calling
them the n-word okay that's insane
and then i love this alejanomar says
sandman's family hired a right-wing pr
firm to write his non-apology
hey what do you think they're going to
do now they're the center of media
scrutiny
you think maybe they're going to talk to
somebody who might know pr yeah and
i love th this has now become a symbol
of sandman's privilege that he that he
hired
a pr firm to deal with the fact that he
had incoming national media trying to
destroy his life
oh god forbid he hires a professional
when professional adults are trying to
destroy him
let me point out that the family of
trayvon martin also had professionals
who were working with them
in other words whenever there is an
incident at the center of american life
pr professionals are there in a
heartbeat because this is legitimately
what they do for a living that's not a
rip on trayvon's family and it's not a
rip on nick sandman's family because all
of this is dumb
we continue by the way to promote the
idea that
nathan phillips is not a liar he is in
fact a liar david french has a good
piece
over at national review today talking
about all the lies that he has told
he falsely has stated that he served in
vietnam two times on cnn
he said he's a vietnam veteran twice
that is not true
and then he said that the black this is
seriously what he says he says that the
kids were looking for trouble
looking for something he disagrees with
the kids defense that phillips came into
their space and they were getting hyped
up he said that's not in the least what
happened but that's exactly what
happened
he said was i what i was witnessing was
just hate racism
well hate what i'm saying is that when
these folks came there these other folks
were saying their piece
and the and these others they got
offended with it because they were both
just expressing their own views
and if it's racism that's what it was
because the folks that were having their
moment there they were saying things
that i don't know if i agreed with them
or not
but some of it was educational and it
was truth and it was history about
religious views and ideologies but these
other folks the young students
they couldn't see it and none of that is
true
it's astounding the adult black hebrew
israelites were taunting the kids
relentlessly as david french writes
these folks are really rage-filled and
and hate-filled i mean they're not the
kind of folks you want to hang around in
your spare time
which is why everyone on the new york
subway ignores them i mean the new york
subway system
a story for another time and then philip
says
that he i mean he just spins the story
completely in a false way and we're
still supposed to take him seriously as
some sort of american hero
he says he says i think that was the
push that we need to use our drum use
our prayer and bring a balance bring a
calming to the situation
that is such a lie he walked into the
middle of a group of students banging
his drum in their faces
he said they were going to hurt them
they were going to hurt them because
they didn't like the color of their skin
there is no indicator that these kids
were going to do anything to the black
hebrew israelites who were taunting the
kids with racial slurs
this is insane and then later he changes
his story
on cnn and he said that one of his
people said they should go reclaim our
space which is really what this was
about
but phillips is a liar he's lying to the
media and in a second
we will show you other stories
demonstrating that
he has been trying to do this sort of
stuff for a while here disrupting other
people's events we'll get to that in
just a second first
let's talk about how you are going to
send your mail this year you need to
head over to stamps.com
if you have a new year's resolution to
make your business more efficient
there's no choice but to use stamps.com
they bring all the amazing services of
the us postal service directly to your
computer
stamps.com is the faster more convenient
way to get postage
simply use your computer to print
official us postage for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it and the mail carrier
picks it up no more logging mail to the
post office no more hassles stamps.com
not only saves you time it saves you
money as well
with stamps.com you get discounted
postage rates that you can't even get
at the post office not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of these expensive
postage meters there's no equipment to
lease
no long-term commitments it's convenient
it's easy it's reliable and it's
efficient you're gonna save time and
you're gonna save money i use stamps.com
here at the daily wire offices
because we don't want our folks having
to wait in line or schlep stuff over in
the car
instead you can just get stamps.com
service right now with a special offer
that includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale to start the
new year off right go to stamps.com
click on that microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in promo code
shapiro that's stamps.com
enter promo code shapiroagainstamps.com
promo code shapiro for that special deal
that includes a four-week trial plus
postage and digital scale go check it
out right now okay so it turns out that
nathan phillips has a habit of trying to
disrupt other people's events
this according to ed condon dateline
yesterday
while chanting and playing ceremonial
drums a group of native american rights
activists
reportedly led by nathan phillips
attempted on january 19th to enter
washington dc's basilica of the national
shrine of the immaculate conception
during a saturday evening mass so
shortly after going after these kids
he decided that he was going to disrupt
a mass the group of 20 demonstrators was
stopped by shrine security
as it tried to enter the church during
its 5 15 pm vigil mass
according to shrine security guard on
duty during the mass it was really
upsetting the guard told catholic news
agency
there were about 20 people trying to get
in we had to lock the doors and
everything
the guard said it was a disappointment
during a busy and joyful weekend for the
shrine said we had hundreds and hundreds
of people
come from all over the country here to
celebrate life to celebrate each other
together
that a protest tried to come inside
during mass was really the worst
he said i'm grateful that nothing bad
happened they were really angry
don't worry nathan phillips is not the
aggressor in any of this he is a pure
victim the church built itself around
him
it's amazing he was just standing there
and boom he was in the middle of a mass
no idea how it happened he didn't try to
wander into the middle of the mass with
his folks
at all what happened is he was just
standing there minding his own business
banging on his drum
and suddenly the church magically
materialized around him
and right in front of him it was just
like
like unbelievable because churches are
racist of course
this is the way we do our news these
days okay in just a second
talk about more of the left's reaction
to all of this because
it is indeed insane and then we're going
to talk about why this is a national
story in the first place because we all
know the real story here why this is a
national story so the press have been
trying to spin this away because this
was a big boo-boo
by a large number of people in the press
here is how the washington post did it
it's their parity of themselves their
parody of themselves abby olheiser and
paul farhy reporting for the washington
post
now here is the rule my friend my friend
andrew clavin
has said this for a long time that when
something when a republican does
something bad
then the story is republican does
something bad when a democrat does
something bad or a leftist does
something bad or the media do something
bad the story is
republican reaction to the bad thing the
story is republicans pounce
and this is this is a rule that you can
apply to all situations in the media and
today is no different here is the
headline from the washington post
a viral story spread the mainstream
media rushed to keep up
the trump internet bounced bounced
okay first of all there should be a
full-time editor whose only job is to
remove the word pounced from all titles
in the media mainstream media
because it's become an actual meme on
the right because we all know where the
media are going to go
we didn't do anything wrong you just
pounced i mean
again listen to that headline the
mainstream media rushed to keep up
no the mainstream media spread the
virality
the mainstream media made it a big story
that headline is absurd but they
continue to say this the video
taken from an instagram account and
reposted to twitter went viral with the
caption
this mega loser gleefully bothering a
native american protester
at the indigenous people's march as the
story picked up speed on social media a
washington post editor assigned
reporters to cover it
at about 3 p.m on saturday one reporter
spoke to phillips about what happened
others called the catholic school and
the local diocese looking for a
statement from someone who could
represent the students in the video
the reporters weren't aware of a
critical third element in the scene the
hebrew israelites who had been taunting
the high school boys moments before the
viral video began
at 5 pm on saturday still unaware of the
moments preceding the viral video the
post published its first story
on what would become a days-long
national argument about racism
the media and masculinity the headline
it was getting ugly
native american drummer speaks on his
encounter with maga hat wearing teens
okay we all know where this story came
from and why they were jumping to that
conclusion
and then they talk about how the the
breaking news
you know made the rounds as is typical
in such breaking news situations
initial news accounts which drew howls
from partisans on both sides were unable
to provide all the context in fact
the hells that were being drawn were
largely the baying of the hounds in the
media
who are going after these kids because
they happen to be wearing maga hats
it took close to 48 hours for reporters
and a divided america to fully grasp
what had occurred
and to whom like many viral outrage
stories the narrative became more
complicated as more facts emerged
and more people stepped forward to talk
about what they saw and experienced in
that moment
but the covington story isn't just a
run-of-the-mill incident
a viral outrage it involved maga hat
wearing teens and a native american
activist
those who shared the video in those
first 24 hours including many
conservatives
seemed to feel it was emblematic of the
vitriol and racism that drives the worst
of american culture
but when new details shifted the story
into more ambiguous territory
a well-oiled machine of pro-trump
personalities and sites
saw an opportunity to strike right so
the only offense here the only
the only thing that was wrong here was
the people who waited and then said that
the media screwed this thing up
because it turns out that the media
screwed this thing up so there's that
really i mean well done media so no need
to re-examine how you go about doing
your business
the real problem here of course is that
people pounced on you
i feel terrible for members i mean what
it must be so difficult to be a member
of the media
when you can just make excuses for your
own malfeasance by saying that people
pounced
pounced okay so there's that which is
great meanwhile joy behar basically let
the cat out of the bag so she was on the
view yesterday talking with
whoopi goldberg and whoopi goldberg was
talking about the rush to judgment
and joy behar sort of let slip the
reason why all of this happened and we
all know we all know
we just instantly say that's what it is
based on what we see in that moment
and then have to walk stuff back when it
turns out we're wrong
why is that why is do we keep making the
same mistake because
because we're desperate to get trump out
of office
i think that that's the reason i think
the press jumps the gun a lot because we
just
we have so much circumstantial evidence
against this guy
that we basically are hoping that you
know cohen's got the goods and what have
you
and so is wishful thinking okay that is
a hundred percent true
and i love that she says us right us
okay because
the us she's talking about that's not
just joy behar it's not just whoopi
goldberg i love the media
you can hear the crowd laughing and
cheering because they know it's true in
other words
if members of the mainstream media who
all think the same way that joy behar
does
decide that these kids must be
sacrificed on the altar of get trump
then they'll do it no problem they have
no problem with that whatsoever and
they're continuing
to promote the stupidest nonsense so the
worst tweet of the day yesterday came
courtesy of kathy griffin
who you know after after holding up a
severed head
of president trump has apparently lost
her head what was left of the brain's
inside is gone
so she tweeted out a photo that was
originally covered by the new york daily
news
right and i i talked about this
yesterday in which
members of the covington catholic high
school were
wearing not blackface but they were
wearing black paint for a blackout game
she found another photo of the covington
catholic students
and some of them are holding up their
hands in the okay motion right which is
they're not even doing that right what
they're really doing is they're holding
up the three-point motion the
three-point motion
for those who have never seen a
basketball game there's a picture of a
basketball game
all these kids are going like this for
people who can see me
all these kids are holding up their
hands like this this is not a white
power symbol in basketball you stupid
morons
it is a three-point signal that is not
me saying it i'm not a professional
basketball player
a fact to which my producers can attest
we have a hoop outside i stink
okay that is a symbol for three-point
motion according to
white supremacists like lebron james
right white supremacists like stephen
cur
stefan curry stephen curry okay
look at there's curry okay so curry is
holding
what he's a white supremacist clearly
according to kathy griffin
making that exact same motion lebron
james has made this exact same motion
like
all nba players make this motion there's
one of the play
who is this one nick um i can't is this
nick young
from lakers i can't remember who this is
in any case a lakers player
making that same motion clearly white
supremacist a black guy like
they're out of their minds jim carrey
another crazed lunatic
who's decided that he's an artist which
is shocking because honest to god my my
five-year-old daughter
draws better than he does he made a
portrait
of people supposedly shouting at nathan
phillips and then above it it says
baby snakes baby snakes according to jim
carrey
so people are just going to continue
lying about this in the same way that
they said hands up don't shoot may not
have been factually accurate but it was
morally accurate and that's the key so
for the left here is how things go
and i've been saying this for weeks now
for years actually
here is how things go the argument is
basically
that if we screw up the facts then
that's okay because our narrative
our underlying narrative is good and if
people on the right say well you screwed
up the facts so this does not prove your
narrative
then people on the left say well that's
because you don't take our narrative
seriously enough so what they'll say is
look at these racist kids and people on
the right will go those kids aren't
racist
and the left will go you're only saying
that the only reason you're even asking
the question is because you don't take
racism seriously enough
and you say well the facts don't back
your accounts it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter
are you saying that racism doesn't exist
in america no i'm not saying that i'm
saying this does not prove your case
nor have you proved your case
evidentiarily just because you say
something doesn't make it true
it's amazing there's a piece by adam
serwer in the atlantic kind of making
the counter case saying
well you know people who are debunking
this particular case
and are now suggesting that there's not
racism in america are wrong
well i'm not sure who's exactly making
that case but it's it is amazing that
folks on the left can't see the counter
that is the mirror negative of that
right the the photo negative of that
argument which is
if you don't got the facts to prove your
case you don't got the facts to prove
your case
and that doesn't prove your narrative
it's pretty incredible okay
in one second i want to talk about the
fresh faces fresh
faces of the new democratic congress
first let's talk about how we can make
your back feel better so
i work out a fair bit i know to look at
me you'd think mild mannered
mild-mannered reporter for the daily
planet in reality underneath
this particular coat lies the body of a
greek god but along with working out
come the aches and pains of being a
professional athlete it means sometimes
my neck hurts sometimes my back hurts
and that's why i have teeter
hanging upside down it turns out is a
fantastic way to decompress the back and
joints after a workout
and boost recovery it's called inversion
therapy which uses gravity and your own
body weight to decompress the spine
release tension
in your shoulders neck and joints i
carry all my attention in my neck
over three million people have put their
trust in teeter they've been the best
known name and inversion table since
and they're offering a great deal just
for my listeners for a limited time you
can get the brand new 2019 teeter fit
spine inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym
teeter and version tables have thousands
of reviews on amazon with an average 4.6
star rating
and with this yield you will get 150 off
when you go to teeter.com
ben you'll also get free shipping free
returns
a 60-day money-back guarantee so there's
absolutely no risk to you to try it out
remember you can only get the new 2019
teeter-fit spine inversion table
plus a free pair of gravity boots by
going to teeter.com
ben that's t-e-e-t-e-r dot com slash ben
again free shipping for your turn 60-day
money back guarantee
and 150 bucks off teeter.com go check
them out make your back
and neck feel better right now okay the
reason the reason that this is a
national story
is because of abortion we all know this
there are only two reasons this is a
national story one
the kids were wearing mega hats and
people in the media hate trump joy behar
is not lying to you
and two this happened at the march for
life and people on the left
are rabid about abortion how rabid are
people on the left about abortion
they are so rabid that the state of new
york just passed a new law
that new law is an egregious destruction
of human life
i mean it's an evil law it's a plain out
evil law
this law basically gets rid of all
restrictions on abortion
it strips abortion from the penal code
so if you
are a person who is pregnant and
somebody hits you in the stomach and the
baby dies
this strips it strips damage to the
fetus out of the
out of the penal code no kidding it's an
incredible incredible
violation of of the rights of the mother
obviously
and then late-term abortions were
legalized again the new law allows a
licensed healthcare practitioner acting
under the scope of their practice
to perform an abortion when according to
the practitioner's reasonable and good
faith professional judgment
based on the facts of the patient's case
the patient is within 24 weeks
from the commencement of pregnancy or
there is an absence of fetal viability
or
this is the key provision the abortion
is necessary to protect the patient's
life or health
health is the key provision there
because protecting the life we all agree
with protecting the health
means you know what i'd be healthier if
i didn't have this nine-month-old baby
right here that's about to enter my
vaginal canal cut its brains out
okay that's what this law now allows the
measure makes late-term abortions legal
at the discretion of a healthcare
practitioner
also so cuomo spoke about this he said
we had to pass this law to protect our
state and then he wants a constitutional
amendment to protect abortion
up to point of birth okay when it comes
to criminal cases
when it comes to criminal cases there is
serious concern
that it limits prosecutors from applying
criminal charges in cases of so-called
forced abortions which can occur during
domestic violence cases
and when a woman loses a child during
pregnancy so a husband beats the living
hell out of his wife and she loses
the baby you can't prosecute him for the
loss of the baby now
senator kathy young republican from
olien cattaraugus county says it is
unconscionable to think that anyone
would deprive a pregnant domestic
violence victim the justice
she deserves and then i love this liz
krueger from manhattan democrats says
you have to ask the question
why would anybody actually use the
abortion code to charge someone with a
heinous crime
we in the state of new york have many
strict rules in our criminal code to
deal with these kind of criminals
so no big deal that the guy killed the
unborn baby we have plenty of ways to
put this guy in jail except that
it put the guy in jail for longer for
committing a crime against a human being
so new york has i mean it's the most
radical law in the nation now
and new york and governor cuomo
celebrated this he's delighted
he ordered that the spire at one world
trade center
the governor mario cuomo bridge the the
kazoo
the uh kosciuszko bridge i don't know
how to pronounce it and the alfred smith
building in albany all be lit
pink on tuesday night and they should
have lit a blood red in honor of the
death of babies
here was the inside of the chamber after
this thing passed
wild applause for the death of the
unborn cuomo said the reproductive
health act is a historic victory for new
yorkers and for our progressive values
in the face of a federal government
intent on rolling back roe v wade and
women's reproductive rights
i promised that we would enact this
critical legislation within the first 30
days of the new session
and we got it done i'm directing that
new york's landmarks be lit pink
to celebrate this achievement and trying
to bright light forward for the rest of
the nation to follow
this act of barbarism stacks alongside
acts of barbarism from the 19
from the 1850s with regard to black
folks the reduction
of babies who just have not entered the
vaginal canal
to pieces of meat that you can easily
dispense with
is dehumanization it is pure simple
dehumanization ending in murder
that's all this is cuomo said on tuesday
it's bittersweet there's bitterness
because we shouldn't be here in the
first place
we should not have a federal government
that is trying to roll back women's
rights this administration defies
american evolution
american evolution as i said in my
speech of the march for life
it's not important that righteousness be
popular it's just important that it be
righteous
if you're evolving toward evil well then
it is our job to stand to thwart the
rails of history
to stop you cuomo is a radical the
democratic party is radical and this is
insanity but this is the reason why they
didn't want to cover the march for life
so they came up with
any excuse they could not to cover the
march for life because they don't want
the messages from the march for life
actually going viral
they don't want to show the section of
my podcast on friday in which i went
through the actual
fetal development stage by stage to show
you how babies in the womb
are developed complete with graphics
they wouldn't show that instead they
would pick out a 21 sec
section as 21 second segment of my show
in which i used an analogy to talk about
why you should not eugenically abort
babies
to prevent future crime rates from
dropping
instead of covering what happened at the
march for life they covered some fake
completely manufactured outrage
about nathan phillips who confronted a
bunch of high school kids and we somehow
made the kids the villains
that's what they will do to avoid
talking about abortion even as they pass
laws
that target the unborn for death okay
meanwhile
the the radicals in the democratic party
have fully taken over
it was bugging me the other day who
alexander ocasio-cortez reminded me
of that because there was like in the
back of my mind there was something that
she reminded me of
and then i realized what she reminds me
of so we're going to play two clips of
alexander ocasio-cortez
back to back or a clip of alexander
ocasio-cortez
and then a clip of her doppelganger so
here she is
yesterday talking about billionaires and
ringworms
with tanahisi codes this is on martin
luther king day talking about why
billionaires should not exist in the
united states and then i will play a
clip of her doppelganger you live in a
more world that allows for billionaires
is that a moral outcome of itself it's
not
um it's not i don't think it's not it
that necessarily means that all
billionaires are immoral but i do think
a system that allows
billionaires to exist when
there are parts of alabama where people
are still getting ringworm because they
don't have access to public health
is wrong okay and then let's
play her doppelganger here
okay now let me just make a point before
the media gets there this isn't sexist
because i make fun of all politicians
repeatedly so get over yourselves
i know as soon as we make fun of aoc
it's sexist it's not sexist to point out
that she has exactly the same mannerisms
and exactly the same political views as
the lady from snl
who seth meyers once brought on as the
as the girl from the party you didn't
actually want to get into a conversation
with
also we're worth noting here it was
funny yesterday i talked a little bit
a little bit about her comments about
billionaires which are innately stupid
and really ridiculous and and her
campaign manager came out and said today
clarified and said billionaires actually
is a staffer billionaires are actually
immoral
it's immoral to want that much money
because once you have enough money you
should stop wanting money
you should stop wanting to produce goods
and services for others instead you
should sort of sit
atop your stack of cash i i focused in
on the billionaire's comment because it
was more relevant
i will simply point out that when
alexander ocasio-cortez
says that people are getting ringworm
for lack of public health
care you get ringworm from skin to skin
contact and from going to the gym when
people haven't cleaned off the treadmill
that's that's how you get ringworm it is
not a public health crisis
that is generated by poverty ringworm
okay it's like you know the serious
public health crisis in this country is
cellulitis
cellulitis is in folliculitis that's
really what we got to worry about
poverty causes folliculitis you're like
what the
what what hot tub folliculitis it's
breaking out everywhere
in cars for homeless people all right
lady
but she is being hailed as the great
hero of the democratic party of course
we'll get to that
in just one second because it's pretty
amazing first you're gonna have to go
over to dailywire.com and subscribe for
9.99 a month you can subscribe to
dailywire.com you get the rest of this
show live you can get the rest
of andrew clavin's show live you get the
rest of michael moles's show live
lots of good stuff plus michael moles's
show and when you subscribe
you also get two more hours of me per
day
i mean my goodness i am slaving away for
you people and what's great is if you're
a subscriber then during the breaks you
can ask me questions i answer the
questions it's really great
so go over and subscribe right now for
99 bucks a year you also get this
the very greatest in beverage vessels
cast your eyes upon it
and despair leftist tears hot oracle
tumbler spectacular
you get that with the annual
subscription thousands of people joining
every single week i mean we are
the group is huge people who want to
support us as they should because we're
doing good work
go check us out over at dailywire.com
also be sure to join us next tuesday
january 29th for daily wire backstage
state of the union coverage
is it going to happen who the hell knows
daily wear god king jeremy boring small
g
small k myself andrew clavin the
excremental michael moles and elisha
krause will be here to cover the
president's speech the left's meltdown
and of course answer your questions as
always only daily wire subscribers get
to ask those questions so be sure to
subscribe today go check that out plus
you need to subscribe to us over at
youtube and at itunes and leave us
reviews and join the club because we
have great sunday specials like this
sunday
we have on lewis howes who's a self-help
guru
and all around awesome guy it's gonna be
great
hey my name is lewis howes and make sure
to tune in to the ben
shapiro show a sunday special where we
cover so many topics
sports religion masculinity
some other cool things as well make sure
to check it out okay so you get all
those great things when you subscribe
and also when you subscribe over youtube
and itunes go check it out right now we
are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast
and radio show in the nation
so one of the things i love most about
aoc we'll get to the tributes to her
the the continued attributes to her it's
it's really amazing
the one of the things i love about her
most really is that
she complains about the media more than
any person i have seen since
donald trump frankly donald trump goes
around and goes fake news but half the
time it's actually fake
aoc complains about things that are not
even fake it's incredible
and the media eat it up like she just
she just whines about people fact
checking her
so she says this quote me i don't think
billionaires should concentrate wealth
while employing people who are sleeping
in cars working a zillion hours to
survive
next day that will be ten pinocchios to
occasio zillion is not a number
and i found someone who sleeps in a tent
not a car okay
one of the fact checkers over at the
washington post glenn kessler he tweeted
back um i asked you some specific
questions about statistics you cited you
refused to answer
and now you're moaning about the fact
that i'm asking you simple questions
that that tweet by her that
intellectually dishonest tweet
143 000 likes because this is the world
that we live in here's the reality if
that
if the girl you don't want to talk to at
a party on snl ran for office she'd win
and she might be president
that's where we are as a country because
nothing she says is distinguishable from
anything that aoc says
because that's where we are and before
people on the left again
say well that's sexist donald trump's
president he was a reality tv star who
didn't know a lot of things
okay so that's not me mocking aoc that's
mocking americans okay
like america get your bleep together
seriously
it's it's it's really spectacular
and then i i love this she also started
tweeting about how
people are mean to her all the time
and the and that she is she's being
targeted by the media
i talked about this a little bit on the
radio show yesterday that the hill
put out a state and put out an article
about her that said
ocasio-cortez i give zero f's about
pushback from other democrats
and then she wrote back i actually
didn't say this so while i know
brown women cursing drives clicks maybe
you actually accurately quote the entire
exchange instead of manipulating people
into thinking
i said this sentence instead of just the
word zero
okay does she know how quotation marks
work like this is a proper use of
quotation marks in this headline she was
asked a question how many fs do you give
and she said
zero the headline says ocasio-cortez i
give
quote zero f's about pushback from other
democrats that is a perfectly accurate
headline but she's moaning about it
because people are so mean to her you
know trump said
i wind and i whine and i whine until i
win and there's something to that
okay folks in politics whine until they
win they're all victims
everything is rough for them it's really
difficult to be aoc especially when they
feature you on the
cover of for of all things the hollywood
reporter i kid you not
aoc on the cover of the hollywood
reporter with the headline aoc
storms sundance so some some lady
made a documentary about ocasio-cortez
and now she's storming sundance really
because there's a documentary about her
i remember my good friend andrew
breitbart there were a couple of
documentaries featuring him there was
one about him called hating breitbart
that's quite good
i don't remember him on the cover of the
hollywood reporter and he actually did
something for a living it really is
truly amazing but that's the nice thing
about being a democrat means never
having to actually be good
at anything or say true things in fact
axios has a piece today
talking about alexander ocasio-cortez's
claim that we're all going to die in 12
years i saw a very funny
a very funny suggestion internally here
is that we should put on a shirt a quote
from aoc the world will end in 12 years
and then it should say alexander
ocasio-cortez for president 2032.
you get the joke got it guys okay so
i'm all for it and but here's what axio
says
the big picture during the past year
several scientific reports have been
released that underscore the urgency
of slashing emissions of greenhouse
gases but while there were only 12 years
left till 2030 when the ipcc report came
out
the reality is that we have a diverse
array of choices before us in terms of
how soon to make emissions cuts
and how significant and costly they are
top climate scientists
told the axios their comments were about
the framing of a rigid 12-year timetable
in general
so they said 12 years isn't the deadline
climate change isn't a cliff we fall off
it's a slope we slide down
that's kate marvel a climate scientist
at nasa we don't have 12 years to
prevent climate change
we have no time it's already here and
even under a business as usual scenario
the world isn't going to end in exactly
12 years
she says she's not wrong that decisions
we make in the next decade will
determine how bad climate change gets
but again the world is not going to end
in 12 years
nor is the 12-year limit the end of the
world like if we don't do anything for
12 years it's not like the world ends
and then there's nothing we can do
is what climate scientists have been
saying about this this is why
sarah huckabee sanders correctly came
out and said um
aoc on climate change yeah we're not
going to listen to her so much that's
not a thing
i think we're going to listen to her on
uh much of anything particularly not
on matters that are we're going to leave
into the hands of a much much
higher authority and certainly not
listen
uh to the freshman congresswoman on when
the world may end
we're focused on what's happening in the
world right now we wish that democrats
like herself would engage in that
conversation
help us fix some of the current problems
we know exist but the race to the left
continues a pace
one of the great things about the 2020
race is we're going to see nothing but
dumb from here on in
you know i really like nothing but
stupid from
here on from here on it's going to be
it's going to be amazing
so an example kristen gillibrand who is
just
delightful i mean she really is she's a
delight because
like hillary clinton she's purely
mechanical like you can actually see the
physical gears turning in her
head when she when she's when she does
things like they've not been greased
there's no smoothness to it it's like
she's a human being who's constantly
doing the robot everything she does is
it's just great and there's also nothing
greater
than watching a white person awkwardly
preach to black people it's one of my
favorite things in the entire world
so kirsten gillibrand went to the
national action network
again it is astonishing to me that al
sharpton is still considered
some sort of legitimate political
influencer inside the democratic party
he's an anti-semitic piece of human
debris
al sharpton he's the worst but democrats
continue to pay homage to him because
anti-semitism acceptable in the
democratic party we we all know this
so kirsten gilbert but this was great
kristen gillibrand went to the national
action network
and she got her preach on it was sort of
like when hillary clinton went down
south
and started talking to black audiences
and suddenly
she started talking like the down-home
arkansas girl we always knew she was
from park parkridge illinois
well kirsten gillibrand is doing the
same thing and it's just spectacular
watch
watch kirsten jillian preach like she
just watched elmer gantry
because we know the truth we speak truth
to power
we will put on the bright breast pit
breath light of righteousness because we
know right from wrong and we will not
forget it we will hold that shield of
faith as dr king said faith
is taking the first step even when you
don't see
the whole staircase so hold on to that
face
tightly she's the best oh man
i really wanted to win the nomination
now it's so great
i love it my favorite you know there's a
famous speech
in which uh in which george h.w bush was
reading the speech off a teleprompter
in the middle of the teleprompter there
was a stage direction and said something
like say with sincerity and so he was
just reading he goes
say with sincerity and like he just
continues reading
that's kirsten gillibrand like you can
like on her speech she's like
put your hand up and she's like and then
she's like
put i want you to wave your hands around
you're like
that's the best thing ever oh i'm really
looking forward to this 2020 race
i mean listen email and in tears of man
with kirsten gillibrand being president
but man if we're gonna buy the ticket we
may as well take the damn ride
because my goodness gracious also worth
noting kamala harris has come out with
her logo
for her for her for her campaign it's
awful
it's a legit it's a legit terrible logo
it's done on like it's like blue and red
on orange
it's a weird color combination really a
really an awful logo so
it's gonna there's gonna be so much fun
during the presidential race i'm so glad
that we get to cover it because
you know what it turns out the world
will not be over soon so that's that's
really
exciting stuff meanwhile the government
shutdown continues a pace and and all
the rest of it but
the real look the government shutdown's
gonna end the real thing that's going to
stay is the radicalism of the democratic
party
alexander ocasio-cortez's newly hired
policy adviser dan riffle
has some strong opinions about bill
gates here is what he tweeted
it's it's it's pretty spectacular he
tweeted
every billionaire is a policy failure
every billionaire is a policy founder
it's a policy failure if somebody makes
too much money
and then he had suggested he deleted his
tweet
in which he encouraged aoc to raise her
top rate not from 70
but to 90 percent he tweeted last night
quote
get ready for this bill gates is money
hoarding makes him greedy
but maybe he goes six for six on the
other deadly sins and on balance is a
good person
still he's a policy failure the
acquisition of that much wealth has bad
consequences
a moral society needs guard rails
against it
i'm gonna need for like a definition of
morality that says
that it is not you being greedy when you
stick your hand in somebody else's
pocket it is greedy when they make their
money
through consensual transactions so bill
gates who has made legitimately millions
of lives better is greedy
you are not greedy for going into his
pocket and stealing his wallet
that's just you establishing moral
justice in the world
pretty amazing so going after bill gates
to to own the cons
well done there by the way bill gates
the democrat bill gates's money hoarding
makes him greedy
but may i i also love hearing democrats
preach
about the seven deadly sins that's one
of my favorite ones well
you know i i think the democrats should
really be the ones preaching
about religious notions of sin right i i
want to hear them preach about lust next
that's the one i hear i want to hear
bill clinton preach about lust i want to
hear them
i want to hear them preach about sloth
and envy you know
there is one of the one of the seven
deadly sins it turns out is envy
does it sound like maybe you're
violating one of the seven deadly sins
when you say that billionaires are
inherently greedy
and that immoral society needs
guardrails against people acquiring
wealth
involuntary transactions might violate
maybe one of the seven sins envy all
right
time for some things i like and some
things i hate so bad news for you today
i have no things i like i've given up
there are no things i like
so let's just do some things that i hate
instead
all right so there's a new york law that
is so
insane i'm not talking about their
abortion law we know that new yorkers
apparently are so far to the left that
they are fine with killing fully fledged
human beings
that's fine apparently but so let's just
get this straight
you can kill a baby in the womb that is
fully formed you cannot kill a person
who breaks into your house
this is according to an opinion piece by
sean roman
struck strockage over at the new york
post
there's a reason homeowners can rarely
afford to dispense mercy on an overnight
invader
criminal intruders tend to be the
dangerous type what homeowners don't
expect are law enforcers and prosecutors
going after them
for defending themselves and their loved
ones queen's resident joel christopher
paul faced a home intruder threat in the
early hours of july 30 2017.
the 27 year old was home in springfield
gardens with his mother brother and
sister when someone attempted to break
in
the intruder was chamel chalvo 26 who
had traveled north from maryland after
being named a suspect in a shooting
there 10 days earlier
expecting a pizza delivery paul's
brother michael 16 went to the door and
discovered chavo trying to break in
michael forced shalvo to the surrounding
area and his mother called for help
joel adrenaline likely surging through
his veins answered the call and brought
a bat and knife to the confrontation
by the time it was all over chalvel
received the ultimate lesson in picking
the wrong house
he died at jamaica hospital after being
clubbed and stabbed
the confrontation had all the
indications of a break and gone wrong
for the wanted man
and as one high-ranking police source
told the post the response was
justifiable
both brother brothers avoided arrest and
remained home after the incident but
months later
queen's d.a richard brown submitted the
case to a grand jury bringing ruin upon
joel who has been charged with
manslaughter
prosecutors shouldn't have targeted joel
the stress expense uncertainty facing a
first degree manslaughter charge are
devastating
and can lead to an unjustified plea that
could result in joel going to prison
part of the trouble lies with new york's
retreat doctrine
so there's something in a lot of states
called the castle doctrine that if
somebody breaks into your house
they are now in your domain and you can
shoot them because they're presumably
they're too too ill
this does not seem like a wild
assumption by the way someone and and
i don't know what the law is i believe
that there's no castle doctrine in the
state of california i believe
but let's just put it this way you're
breaking my house you're getting shot in
the face that's how that's going just
warning to all intruders you break into
my physical domicile
i'm gonna assume you are there not to
play pinochle and i will shoot you in
the face
and this is the perspective of all
second amendment abiding gun owners
across the united states you break into
our houses you're getting shot that's
the way this is going
but new york has a retreat doctrine the
doctrine holds that joel had a duty to
run
and hide if it was safe to do so it's an
obligation joel like the vast majority
of new yorkers had probably never heard
of because it's asinine
yet it's likely the queen's ga will
pursue precisely this avenue at trial
since the indictment states that joel
with intent to cause serious physical
injury to chamel chavel caused his death
while most jurisdictions would have left
joel alone the queen ca seems to want to
resurrect the city's bad old days
when prosecutors developed a reputation
of interpreting laws in ways that
protected criminals
more than they protected victims okay
this is insanity it's violation of the
basic right to self-defense
government was established to protect
you and your property it was not
established to protect criminals who
break into your home
and this is not a i mean this should not
be a racial issue it shouldn't be
that if you're a white person defending
your home then everybody is okay with it
if you're a black person protecting your
home or a brown person protecting your
home then everybody is very upset about
it
and this guy should be acquitted
immediately there's no way that this
person ever should have been
indicted in the first place if we are
getting the true story from the new york
post here
if someone breaks into your house you
have a right naturally given to you by
god
to shoot that person in the head no one
gets to break into your home
this is absurd this is absurd now
there's something called assumption of
the risk in tort law
you assume the risk you're going to get
shot when you accost somebody violently
that's that's the way this works all
right well we will be back here a little
bit later today with two more hours of
grandiose wonderful coverage this is why
you should subscribe over at
dailywear.com so you can see that
you can actually see the show if you're
listening to radio we are i'm live all
over the country 150 plus stations at
this point but
you can't see the show on demand you
can't hear the show commercial free if
you want to do all those things you have
to subscribe over at dailywire.com so go
check that out
over at dailywire.com we'll see you here
later or tomorrow this is the ben
shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
senya villarreal executive producer
jeremy boring senior producer jonathan
haye
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by adam syevitz
audio is mixed by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by jessua olvera production
assistant nick sheehan the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2019